30,000 جنيه لصندوق الاسره وقاضي يقرر مدى
توافق الطرفين لاتمام الزواج الجده الكبير
حول شروط جديده للزواج في مصر القصه
[موسيقى]
جد الكبير شهدوا المجتمع الفتره اللي فاتت
بسبب نشر معلومات معلوطه حول مشروع قانون
جديد للاحوال الشخصيه بيتم اعداده حاليا
والجدل بدا بعد الاعلان عن صندوق دعم
الاسره اللي هيموله المقبلين على الزواج
حديثا ومساهمه كمان من الحكومه وده هيتم
بعد ما يتحدد مبلغ معين هيدفعوا لعريس
ويضاف الى مصروفات عقد القرار
[موسيقى]
خاصه الدوله
دوله مستقبلهم من خلال الصندوق
كمان تضمن القانون شروط اخرى للزواج زي
فحوصات طبيه للطرفين للتاكد من صحتهم
النفسيه والجسديه وعرضهم امام القاضي
للاقرار بملاءمتهم وتوافقهم مع بعض واعطاء
الاذن للماذون بقد القرار
ومن هنا بدات الاشاعات في الانتشار فالبعض
روق لان الرسوم الصندوق هتتروح بين 30
و40,000 جنيه واشعه ثانيه بان العروسين
هيتعرضوا امام القاضي ولل اقر انهم مش
مناسبين زوجهم مش هيتموا بامر القانون
[موسيقى]
دي كانت ان الفتره اللي فاتت شهدت عدد
الضغط
من تلك القيود وده اللي وصفوا لبعض
بالكارثه لان كثير من الزياده دي اطرافها
ما كانوش اخذوا فتره كافيه للتاكد من
توافقهم مع بعض وان التسرع في الزواج ممكن
يسبب مشاكل تؤدي الى الانفصال السريع كمان
وبعد ايام من الغلط خرج وزير العدل في
تصريحات تلفزيونيه ونفى تحديد قيمه رسوم
صندوق دعم الاسره واكد فيما يخص التحاليل
ان نتائجها مش هتمنع الزواج هي فقط هتعطي
الاختيار الطرفين في الاستمرار في علاقتهم
او لا واكد على سريتها وزهر سمها
وفيما راى البعض القانون الجديد هيشكل بعض
القيود للمقبلين على الزواج راى اخرون ان
مشروع القانون الجديد هيقلل جدا من نسب
الطلاق خاصه بعد التاكد ان الطرفين لبعض
من خلال الاختبارات والتحاليل
[موسيقى]
وانتم مع من تتفقون